وصل الخبز اليومي إلى رغيفين
لكل شخص في مدينة بهاموت الواقعة على خط المواجهة
في شرق أوكرانيا
، ولا يوجد غاز هنا ، ولا تعمل المخابز ،
لذا يتم نقل 10000 رغيف
هنا 10 ساعات كل يوم
تأتي الزنبق مع
أحفادها و  تقول إنها تحاول
حمايتهم من أصوات الحرب
ونخبرهم أن هناك بعض اللاعبين يلعبون
بالدبابات ، وتقول كيف يمكنني إلحاق الضرر
بصحتهم العقلية ، ولا يجب أن تفعل
ذلك لأنه من المستحيل
أن يكون هدير النار الأوكرانية الخارجة
يد متطوع يساعد
العيش خارج الخبز
أمر غير وارد ،
لدي طفلان وأربعة
أحفاد قالت لي إنني أحبهم
جميعًا أريد أن نعيش جميعًا هنا ، إنها
أرضنا كل شيء سيكون على ما يرام الله
يحمينا
الوظيفة هي التحقيق في كل ضربة في كل
مبنى متضرر  بالنسبة للغارة الجوية لشرطة باهاموت
في
أي وقت
في الصباح
في المساء ،
لا نعرف
متى يكون هناك ضرر للناس ، وهو
يأخذنا إلى مدرسة
قصفتها الطائرات الحربية الروسية الأربعاء
الثاني من المارة  s-by
لم يتم احتجاز صفوف المصابين منذ شهور
ليست ببعيد ، فقد أصيب مجمع من
المستودعات الزراعية العمال
وهم ينقذون ما يمكن أن
تقصفه شظاياهم في سقف أحد
المستودعات التي تحتوي على مورد ثمين
لا نعرف دوافعه.
الروس لضربهم هذه المنشأة ،
تم ضربها ثلاث مرات مؤخرًا
صباح يوم الخميس ، لكن لا يسع المرء إلا أن
يتساءل عما إذا كانت كل هذه الحبوب الأوكرانية
هي الهدف
udmilan كان طفلاها
يقيمان في مهجع تديره هذه المدينة منذ
مسيرة هربا من القصف الذي وقع بالقرب منها
لقد فكرت في المغادرة إلى جزء أكثر أمانًا
من البلاد ولكن ليس لديها ما يكفي من
المال وفي النهاية تسأل عن
الهدف من قدوم الروس
لكن الآخرين لم يتم تذكيرهم بالقدرية
بينما ينتظرون خروج الحافلة من المدينة
لماذا  يجب أن يذهب
مربي النحل في وقت السلم
يغادر مع قطته سيمون سيميونيك بن ويتمان CNN
أوكرانيا